toi la folle toi petit coureuses tu te
casses la gueule et tu te relèves dans
un rire mais le rire c'est un crache à
la gueule du monde
le salle rit remis la trop belle mila
super toi la bête quand ça prend le
dessus quand ça vient au dessus les je
m'en fous allez vous faire [ __ ]
allez-y voir j'aimerais bien vous y voir
j'ai lu une phrase et c'était comme toi
comme tu es quand tu parles pas j'en ai
assez de ce qui est joli j'en ai assez
de ce qui est intime je boxe sur des
tempêtes et je coulerait sans personne
pour me sauver cherche pas mis là tu
coulera pas tu flottes oublie tous les
mecs qui marche avec des tonnes de kilos
dans les pieds je les vois les mecs qui
se plante
ils croient qu'ils ont le poids sur les
épaules mais c'est dans leurs pieds et
leurs beaux chalets dans leurs pieds
aussi et les points pour frapper dans
les pieds alors bien sûr ça marche pas
bien tu captes attends je recommence on
est là on sait pas où on en est mais on
sait où on est on est partout ailleurs
on sait toi avec tes je m'en fous je
flotte moi avec mes pieds comme les
autres ont couvert le fond un peu vers
le vent hop là
prends-moi 1001 soulève moi juste un peu
tirait partout avec toi est un vide qui
tu veux me le gamin si tu veux les
cheveux au vent qui chialent bien bien
fort regarde regarde écoute mais laïque
où tu fais comme tu veux bien sûr qu'au
tour ça se casse toujours la gueule en
disant tiens toi droite
il suffit de bouger un tout petit peu la
tête presque pas visibles pour que tout
s'écroule mais pas nous enfin tout ça tu
sais déjà